[Música]
confiamos en la soberanía de dios y dios
dirige a eeuu
[Música]
y también quiero vivir en una sociedad
moralmente fuerte donde las familias
sean fuertes
creo que la religión es un prerrequisito
para el gobierno es la herramienta para
controlar a las masas
bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de
postales de campaña la cobertura
especial de france 24 en estas
elecciones presidenciales de eeuu con
nosotros viajarán a los seis estados que
decidirán al presidente de este país los
próximos cuatro años y nuestro viaje hoy
nos lleva a georgia un estado
tradicionalmente republicano donde el
voto evangélico tiene muchísimo peso en
los últimos años la población se ha
vuelto más diversa y también las
opiniones públicas pero antes de entrar
en detalles veamos algunos datos que nos
permitirán conocer mejor esta zona del
sur del país que sabemos de georgia
situada entre el océano atlántico
florida y carolina del norte y carolina
del sur georgia se encuentra en el
corazón del sur de eeuu
georgia es un estado de contrastes
montañas en el norte con la cordillera
de los apalaches y llanuras en el sur
con 10,6 millones de habitantes georgia
es uno de los estados más poblados del
país la mayoría de la población se
concentra en el norte de la región de la
capital
atlanta atlante es además el centro de
la economía del estado cde de
importantes compañías como lluvias delta
airlines y cocacola la comunidad
afroamericana está muy presente en
georgia 33% de la población del estado
también es el lugar de nacimiento del
movimiento de derechos civiles el
electorado está bastante dividido
mientras que los afroamericanos y los
votantes graduados blancos votan a los
demócratas las áreas rurales tienden a
ser republicanas georgia también alberga
una gran población de cristianos
evangélicos un electorado clave para el
donald trump georgia ofrece 16
el colegio electoral en 2016 donald
trump ganó con el 54% de los votos el
estado no ha votado por un candidato
demócrata desde bill clinton en 1992
[Música]
la unión política entre republicanos y
evangélicos se ha mantenido firme los
últimos 47 años sobre todo aquí en
georgia en el corazón del llamado
cinturón bíblico una zona al sur del
país en la que se concentran la mayoría
de evangélicos blancos representan un 26
por ciento del electorado en todo el
país y para ellos estas elecciones son
más importantes que nunca confían en que
donald trama al que ven como el
mensajero de dios peleará por las
libertades religiosas y detendrá los
abortos
donald trump por su parte ha peleado
mucho por este voto incluso ha empujado
para que se eligiera contrarreloj una
jueza conservadora en la corte suprema
además los evangélicos cuentan también
con el apoyo del vicepresidente may
pensé en la casa blanca pero será todo
esto es suficiente para ganar el estado
de georgia un equipo de france 24 ha
buscado respuestas en la capital del
estado en atlanta
[Música]
durante los últimos cuatro años dios ha
tenido competencia en el cinturón
bíblico donald trump se ha hecho un
lugar en esta zona rural pero aquí la
vida sigue girando en torno a la
religión no a la política en georgia el
40% de la población es cristiana
evangélica el grupo de viudas de la
iglesia de rock sprint organiza una
comida para el personal de la parroquia
el invitado de honor es el pastor
benítez
desde el fondo de mi corazón gracias a
todas por hacer esto por nuestro
personal no puede quedarse por mucho
tiempo
el pastor dirige lo que los
estadounidenses llaman una mega iglesia
seis mil feligreses diez veces la
población de mílner la ciudad donde se
encuentra ubicada cuando benítez asumió
el cargo hace 30 años había sólo unas
pocas decenas de feligreses hoy en día
está al frente de algo más que una
iglesia una escuela un refugio para
personas sin hogar producción de
cortometrajes las mega iglesias también
se definen por su peso en una comunidad
y por supuesto aquí late el corazón de
la congregación un santuario de 4
millones de dólares
esta sala tiene capacidad para unas 1100
personas
puesto nuestro equipo de alabanza estará
aquí arriba yo estaría allí en el
púlpito y predicar y a muchas vidas han
cambiado aquí tuvimos algunos servicios
increíbles en este edificio en dos veces
en desborden todos los domingos ven y te
da tres servicios windows words nos
respaldamos al partido republicano no
respaldamos al partido demócrata
y nos ocuparemos de los temas bíblicos y
diremos que esta es la enseñanza bíblica
en esta área
eeuu lo logrará sin importar quién sea
elegido porque nuestra confianza no está
en quién está en la casa blanca es
nuestra confianza está en quién está en
el trono confiamos en la soberanía de
dios y dios dirige a eeuu
galliano américa dios cuida de eeuu pero
los estadounidenses cuidan su creación
crecí en una escuela cristiana desde el
preescolar hasta la graduación continúe
siendo cristiana toda mi vida diría que
mi fe es el mayor pilar que tengo en la
vida
kerry mets es una cristiana evangélica y
defensora del medio ambiente en su
comunidad muchos niegan el cambio
climático kerry no entiende la oposición
entre la ciencia y la fe creo que no hay
nada más prohibida que enfrentar el
cambio climático la ciencia es una de
las cosas más cristianas que tenemos es
la forma en que dios se nos muestra dios
quiere que seamos inteligentes quiere
que seamos pensadores la biblia dice que
dios nos llama a ser guardianes de
nuestro planeta nos llamó a cuidar
nuestro planeta
kerry acaba de mudarse a los suburbios
de atlanta aún no ha encontrado su nueva
iglesia
ah
i
creo que la nueva candidata de la corte
suprema no es una muy buena opción
también me preocupan sus fuertes
inclinaciones religiosas y como eso
afectará a los derechos de las mujeres
aquí en eeuu
como cristiano yo personalmente no creo
en el aborto pero lo que las demás
personas hagan tendrán que responder
ante dios por esas acciones
creo que el aborto es un tema en todo
eeuu y también la manera en la que están
tratando de transferir un derecho humano
básico que es la autonomía corporal creo
que la religión es un prerrequisito para
el gobierno es la herramienta para
controlar a las masas así es creo que
eso es más de lo mismo
y
y para entender mejor el voto evangélico
blanco hemos querido hablar con uno de
sus líderes con el doctor ralph read que
es el presidente de la coalición fe y
libertad una organización sin fines de
lucro que defiende la política social
conservadora con cerca de 2 millones de
miembros además usted ha participado en
varias campañas electorales y trabaja de
hecho en la de donald través de 2020 y
precisamente sobre el presidente es la
primera pregunta que queremos hacerles
sobre la moralidad del presidente hace
cuatro años muchos evangélicos dudaron
de ella se han disipado estas dudas creo
que esa duda se disiparon hace tiempo
tuvimos el beneficio de cuatro años de
su liderazgo y creo que la mejor manera
en la que podría resumir lo sería en
cuatro palabras promesas hechas promesas
cumplidas él fue el primer candidato
presidencial en la historia de eeuu en
publicar una lista de jueces y jurados y
decir que iba a llenar un puesto vacío
en la corte suprema de eeuu con alguien
de esa lista
y lo hizo no una o dos sino tres veces y
es el único presidente en la historia de
eeuu en haber hecho algo así lo ha hecho
otras doscientas veces para otros jueces
federales cumplió su palabra de mover la
embajada de eeuu de tel aviv a jerusalén
ahí reconocer a jerusalén como la
capital de israel cumplió su palabra en
la reducción de impuestos cumple su
palabra en ser pro-vida entonces creo
que en ese punto o sea no se trata de la
fe tiene un historial comprobado de
éxitos y logros y creo que respaldarán a
donald trump de manera mucho más amplia
en 2020 de lo que hicieron en 2016
como mantenido donald trump a esa
promesa que hizo hace cuatro años de
poner límites al aborto restauró inglés
por su la política de ciudad de méxico
que previene que el dinero de los
contribuyentes se utilice para promover
el aborto a través de programas de
planificación familiar extranjeros fue a
la corte federal y defendió a las
hermanitas de los pobres y a otras
organizaciones cristianas que fueron
obligadas bajo el obamacare a pagar por
el aborto e inducción de medicamentos
no sólo se trataba de un asunto de
aborto era un asunto de libertad
religiosa le quitó la financiación a la
planificación familiar en la línea del
programa de prevención del embarazo
adolescente y también se convirtió en el
primer presidente en la historia de eeuu
sin hablar en la marcha por la vida hay
argumentos muy sólidos para decir que ha
sido el presidente más pro vida en la
historia de eeuu qué opina de la
decisión de donald trump sobre esa silla
que quedó vacía de la corte suprema
que estamos absolutamente emocionados
hemos sido grandes seguidores de la
jueza barrett por mucho tiempo
es una candidata muy impresionante tiene
un gran intelecto brillante es una
académica legal muy respetada
es un ejemplo de una promesa que el
creciente hizo y cumplió
con la denominación de emi con y ballet
no sólo tenemos una oportunidad de poner
en la corte a una mujer madre de hijos
que van a la escuela que por primera vez
estaría en la corte y volvería a traer
la perspectiva de una mujer en esa etapa
de su vida y también una mujer devota de
fe una mujer para quien su fe cristiana
es muy importante y ha sido atacada por
eso como cristiano evangélico cuál es su
visión de una sociedad de estadounidense
ideal
quiero ver una sociedad próspera con
abundancia para todos me gustaría que la
pobreza sea disminuyendo y que el empleo
siga aumentando también tengo una visión
de sociedad en la cual todo el mundo
pueda vivir en un vecindario seguro
libre de la plaga del crimen y de las
drogas y también quiero vivir en una
sociedad moralmente fuerte donde las
familias sean fuertes donde las personas
sean devotas de dios' como quiera que lo
entiendan donde las familias que estén
intactas esa es parte de nuestra visión
para las personas con una familia y un
matrimonio intactos y saludables porque
creemos que ese es el departamento de
salud educación y bienestar más exitoso
que se pueda concebir padres amorosos y
un hogar amoroso pueden hacer mucho
mejor trabajo que cualquier plan
gubernamental
muchas gracias por estar con nosotros en
el episodio de hoy y pegar
[Música]
en estados unidos en más de 95 millones
de evangélicos y la mayoría de ellos
apoyan a donald trump pero no todos
fuera que eran los más progresistas y
los afroamericanos que se decantan por
el lado demócrata precisamente este
último grupo de la población los
afrodescendientes han sido los más
castigados por la cob y 19 en este país
y para conocer el impacto que la
pandemia ha tenido en ellos y en estas
elecciones presidenciales ponemos rumbo
a nuestro siguiente destino florida
acompáñenos en este viaje a través de
nuestras redes sociales con el numeral
postales de campaña ese 24 fue en la
página web cast 34 punto com
[Música]